a u.s military aircraft touches down in
poland near the border with ukraine
on board a few dozen elite u.s troops
and equipment
the initial contingent of around 1
700 u.s soldiers ordered to head to
europe because nato countries fear a
russian invasion of ukraine deployment
of elements of the 82nd airborne
division are here to enhance
the readiness interoperability across
all domains
with our polish allies
and if necessary defend any portion of
nato satellite pictures supplied by a
private u s company have been published
which is said to show the latest russian
troop build-up in belarus
ukraine's neighbor and russia's ally
the russian military buildup includes
nuclear-capable bomber patrols part of
moscow's huge joint exercise with
belarus called operation resolve
the kremlin says 11 days of war games
starting on thursday are aimed at
training to repel
an attack on russia's southern borders
the white house national security
adviser said negotiations with russia
was still an option but time is running
out we believe that there is a very
distinct possibility that vladimir putin
will order an attack on ukraine it could
take a number of different forms it
could happen as soon as tomorrow or it
could take some weeks yet there was a
different milder tone from the ukrainian
government ukraine's foreign minister
tweeted do not believe the apocalyptic
predictions different capitals have
different scenarios but ukraine is ready
for any development
today ukraine has a strong army
unprecedented international support and
ukrainians faith in their country this
enemy should be afraid of us not us
afraid of them
another example of kiev's cautious
attempt at toning down the language of
its western backers after president
vladimir zelinski told his us-led allies
last week to take a breath and calm down
russia still maintains it has no
intention of invading ukraine but of
course if it did
that would be the second invasion in
recent years because of its annexation
of crimea in 2014
after weeks of negotiations between nato
countries and russia there has been no
significant outcome to those talks the
french and the german leaders are
heading to moscow and kiev in the coming
days
the space for a negotiated settlement to
this crisis is small but it still exists
charles stratford al jazeera svetohirsk
eastern ukraine